what's going on guys this is rob and i
am recovering from the flu so you're
gonna have to pardon me being a little
bit nasally uh
yeah it sucks
i'm pretty congested but uh in any event
so we are covering the story where
andrew garfield spider-man kills all the
villains in marvel comics or kills all
his villains technically it's not andrew
garfield but i feel like it would be
andrew garfield i don't know about you
guys from time to time i like to take
characters from the marvel cinematic
universe and like put them in the comics
right like put their faces to characters
in the comics and just kind of go from
there and we know we're getting amazing
spider-man 3 it's probably going to be
dark so it would be awesome if it was
this story so we're going to pretend
that it's andrew garfield spider-man
just do this with me and then let me
know how you feel about it at the end i
feel like you'll like it so what this
does this this initial issue anyway is
this picks up basically with spider-man
getting the venom symbiote in the
aftermath of secret wars now a little
bit of history here for those of you
guys who aren't familiar with this right
so we've talked about this multiple
times so we're not going to go super in
depth into this but the long and short
of it is that in marvel comics when they
did secret wars in 1984 peter parker got
what was in effect the venom symbiote we
just simply didn't know what it was and
it wasn't until he got back to earth
that we basically learned the whole
thing was essentially a living organism
so what this does is it basically opens
up seemingly immediately after secret
wars when he gets back to earth and
that's why a lot of the characters that
you're going to see in this comic are
going to look the way they did back in
the 1980s because that's basically when
this comic takes place and so peter
parker waking up really from these
nightmares that he initially had which
is also kind of this idea that he's
being tormented by quote unquote his
best the fact that like his best isn't
necessarily good enough right that uncle
ben died that when stacey died things
like that and that even though he's
tried his best it's led to the death of
people that he cares about that what it
does is it kind of weighs on it and so
the symbiote ultimately bonds itself to
peter and then peter using the symbiote
basically goes out into the world now
this is really peter parker
experimenting with it and seeing what it
was capable of when he was using it as a
superhero on earth and so what he ends
up doing is coming across a guy who's
basically trying to uh trying to mug an
older lady and then of course you know
kind of pummels them a little bit as you
normally do when you're spiderman and
then webbed them up and then essentially
left right not a whole lot doing there
where things begin to get dark is when
the the symbiote kind of communicates
with him and talks to him while he
sleeps almost feeding him these
nightmares and then when mary jane
watson tries to wake him up he actually
smacks her into a wall and then almost
hurts her right and kind of does to
agree nothing serious but enough to
where what's happening with peter
regarding the symbiote is beginning to
to concern mary jane watson right that
he's basically unraveling as far as she
can tell right that he's kind of falling
apart this symbiote is having an effect
on him now the first real instance of us
seeing him really falling to his darker
side comes when he runs into roderick
kingsley now in marvel comics at the
time roderick kingsley was the hobgoblin
hobgoblin was kind of like the green
goblin-esque scenario uh just sort of a
follow-up to the popularity of the green
goblin in his own right hobgoblin was
every bit as interesting as the green
goblin was was he on the same level no i
mean he was not the same kind of
threat that green goblin was he
certainly didn't have the same kind of
significant impact on the life of peter
parker that green goblin had but he
still is a credible and dangerous threat
and so as the fight breaks out between
the two of them what roderick kingsley's
doing here is not outside the the realm
of normality in terms of how he fights
right just not caring about anybody
caught in the in in collateral damage
and peter parker trying to save people
where he can right it's kind of the
dance that villains and heroes do the
difference about this is that peter
begins to get the upper hand on
hobgoblin and instead of just like
grabbing him and carting him off to the
cops and calling it a day he's basically
like i'm tired of you right like i'm
tired of this back and forth game that
we've been doing and he basically rips
his mask off which is something that
he's just not really supposed to do is
kind of violating the sort of unwritten
rule of the hero and and villain
dichotomy realizing that it's roderick
kingsley and then saying like if you
keep this up i'm not gonna send you to
prison you are doing nothing more than
solidifying to me that you as villains
cannot be redeemed so if you keep on
with your villainous ways i will end
your life and then just leaves right
just just like takes off and so
following that you do get a couple
things that are sort of interesting here
most notably in the early days when you
had felicia hardy who was introduced in
marvel comics as black cat there was a
lot of flirtation going on there right
like relationships and all that kind of
stuff and one of the things that gets
hit on here is that peter parker
actually cheats on mary jane watson with
felicia hardy now this is huge and the
reason why is because while mary jane
watson by this point in peter parker's
life had not reached the level of the
love of his life in the wake when stacy
had that they were in a relationship and
peter was never really the one to cheat
on the girl that he was with right it
was just this kind of rule of peter
parker and really just superheroes in
general you don't really step out on the
person that you're dating this is
designed to kind of illustrate that
peter's fallen pretty hard pretty fast
right now here's a crazy thing it's only
the tip of the iceberg because at that
point you switch over to reed richards
the fantastic four now this also
happened in the main marvel universe
right that when peter was experiencing
these kind of nightmares and things like
that that things seemed off right that
he would basically wake up and it was
obvious he would he had been out in the
world despite the fact that he'd been
asleep that the symbiote seemed to have
been the one that caused it that when he
went to visit reed richards things
happen almost exactly like they do here
albeit the situation or some of the
things that take place are a little bit
different but the experimentation on
peter analyzing the symbiote different
things like that coming to this
realization that the symbiote is a
living organism now while this takes
place peter has a kind of conversation
with the symbiote itself where it shows
him these almost tormenting experiences
right where it's like you could help all
these people peter you could help all
these innocent people your aunt may
these people that that are still in your
life although you've lost gwen stacy
uncle them things like that you can help
them and it's okay to hurt people to
save people you know that sometimes the
only way to stop a threat is to
eliminate the threat once and for all
and where peter is reluctant to it
ultimately the symbiote seems to get the
upper hand on him and is like no peter
you have to be strong now remember peter
still has a measure of control here and
he ultimately ends up waking up and
that's when reed richards tells him this
thing's alive man it's a sentient being
right like this thing that's on your
body it's a living organism and it's
feeding on your thoughts and you're
feeding on its thoughts right it is
really more of a symbiotic relationship
not necessarily your parasitic but if
you keep it long enough it will control
you and where reed tries to basically
find a way to tell peter to take it off
right where peter goes to leave that
peter doesn't really attack him so much
you just kind of initiate a show of
force by just kind of you know grabbing
the hand of reid and just being like
that's not gonna happen and so once
peter leaves and he heads back home to
aunt may that the hobgoblin roderick
kingsley is actually watching him and so
as he's there without may his spider
sense goes off and roderick kingsley
attacks and this is what it all takes
off because at that point with
everything going on right rotter
occasionally kind of says like you
started this peter right you struck
first threatening me unmasking me
telling me you were gonna kill me if i
continued my villainous career right
that's not how this works you escalated
and i matched in kind and so when all
this happens there's actually an
explosion that takes place in the house
of aunt may the whole place catches fire
but because symbiotes are weak to fire
the simian will not let peter parker
into the house and ultimately aunt may
dies and when that happens peter loses
it he absolutely goes off right and then
turns all the frustration and anger he
has towards roderick kingsley that where
roderick is kind of walking away and was
like okay this was obviously a mistake
to push you know push spider-man like
this that basically he gets webbed up
and then in turn peter's just like you
started this rotary kingsley but i will
finish it right like you can you cannot
be fixed like you literally came here to
my house and attacked my family and got
my aunt may killed i have the power to
end you i have the power to stop
everything that you're doing and with
great power must also come great
responsibility and he undertakes the
responsibility of ending roderick
kingsley of killing him like literally
he crushes his skull and leaves him for
dead like
it's not like he hides the body or
anything it's not like he keeps it
hidden or anything like that like
literally just leaves him right just
leaves him attached to a light post and
just walks away so everybody knows that
it was spider-man who did it and so what
you get at that point is you get this
whole kind of discussion between peter
and venom that where peter initially
resisted where peter initially was like
no we can't take this darker path that
because of the fact that it's really
been a kind of emotional war of
attrition right that the venom sami has
just kind of been weighing on and
weighing on him and weighing on like
pushing him pushing him pushing him over
and over and over again that combined
with the the the circumstances that just
took place peter's at his weakest and
that's when it basically talks him into
this idea that he basically put an end
to hobgoblin because it's what needed to
be done that the only way to stop
criminals is to kill criminals because
if those criminals could revert or could
leave that life of crime they would have
they choose to be criminals they desire
to be criminals and as long as there's
no real consequences for the things they
do they will continue to be criminals
and that in this kind of situation
criminals inflict violence therefore the
only way to make a criminal understand
is to speak a language they understand
which is to meet violence with violence
right to destroy them it's why i always
say violence is not always the answer
but it is a answer and it's usually a
very effective one and so following that
of course the daily bugle immediately
figures out what's going on with with
hobgoblin right roderick kingsley killed
and they're publishing it all over the
place right they're just like you know
is spider-man uh a threat or a murderer
right you know that kind of a thing and
so while that's happening and peter's
kind of coming to terms with the fact
that the daily bugle is basically
painting him as a killer which he
essentially is you switch over to the
kingpin and the crazy thing about this
is that kingpin looking at all this
unfold is like okay so yes we basically
figured out that it was spider-man who
killed hobgoblin well now spider-man's
basically taking this step to where he's
killing villains we don't know under
what circumstances he's doing it we
simply just know that he is and kingpin
ever the pragmatist looks around and
says okay so i'm literally the kingpin
of crime
i've got my hand in everything right
like my my criminal empire cannot handle
my death therefore i am not willing to
die so we're going to make some calls
and we're going to get rid of spider-man
and so what you do is you switch over to
the daily bugle and one of the more
interesting moments where jay jonah
jameson is always being j john jameson
right just kind of being a dick but it's
all about creating these articles you
know publishing spider-man as a
basically a killer when spider-man shows
up and then basically tells him if you
keep on publishing this i'm gonna kill
you breaks his hand and then leaves like
literally threatens the press right it's
it's pretty insane and so obviously this
is drawing the attention of everybody
right not even just super villains it's
drawing the attention of superheroes
right spider-man's going rogue and
spider-man's killing people and so
because of this you actually end up
switching to him first being attacked by
the shocker not elektro right the
shocker is a poor man's version of
electro but basically being attacked by
the shocker but because shocker is what
he considers to be some kind of
second-rate thief right a low-level guy
there's no way he'd make a move on peter
by himself and that makes sense the only
time you ever really saw the shocker
doing something like this right making a
move on peter is if he was part of a
larger group where he believed he could
get the upper hand but pewter realizing
something else is going on comes to this
realization the scorpion's there as well
and so he ends this like that like he
literally uses his symbiote to overcome
the scorpion and basically kill him and
then in turn attack shocker and then
kill shocker shows up on the doorstep of
kingpin and then throws the severed arm
of the shocker on the floor and then
basically throws the pieces of scorpion
on the floor as well and that where he
goes through and says okay so like we've
been researching you right like you know
when you murdered hot goblin i had my
men research the woman who died in the
fire mae parker to provoke such a
reaction she must have been someone
close to you our best match was a man
named peter parker you so i went about
investigating seeing if you had any
other close family members a wife a
girlfriend someone i could threaten but
there was no one so incredibly sad you
have no one peter parker anyone you've
ever loved is dead and then in turn he
kills kingpin just like that like it's
the ruthlessness of peter parker like
literally just killing people just on a
whim right just killing people and so at
that point it breaks down to the
sinister six right you literally get
doctor octopus mysterio craven the
hunter rhino electro you get this team
assembled and they're like okay so the
death of the hobgoblin is really what
what brings in auto octavius right
because at that point now we're getting
into upper echelons right i mean it's
one thing to kill the shocker it's one
thing to kill scorpion whatever but when
the kingpin is killed a guy who is by
all standards of measurement untouchable
then now they know peter means business
right so that's why octavia says like
the death of hobgoblin fists sent
shocker and scorpion after him and now
well they're all dead and we're next so
this isn't really necessarily the
sinister six taking on any kind of a
superhero role it's really an act of
survival like they look at the actions
of peter and they look at their role as
villains and is like peter's gonna come
after us it's only a matter of time
before he does and it doesn't even have
to be because we're villains right we
could just stop being villains right now
and just walk away right but it could be
any number of the things that we've done
before because you know from their
perspective peter's lost his mind i mean
they don't know he's peter right like
you know they know spider-man's lost his
mind but they're like we don't know why
he would attack us right it could be
because he views us as people that were
previously villains and even though
we've hung up our spurs and we're not
villains anymore we could go back to a
life of crime and that's just not a
threat he wants to deal with so he just
kills us so we don't have to worry about
it but the other part of this is that
they've actually been brought together
and unified by jay jonah jameson who's
like he has to be stopped right like
i've tried to warn people for years
spider-man is a menace nobody wanted to
believe me and now he's killing people
right now people are believing me and so
in turn the response of otto is okay yes
like it's time for us to do something we
have to put our plan in motion and so at
that point it's a matter of trying to
find who it is or at least where they
can lure spiderman or what kind of trap
they can set to bring spider-man to
basically their best location to where
they could take him out right standard
sinister sick stuff only for us to find
out that one of the henchmen who's there
a guy by the name of terence kills dr
octopus right stabs this guy in the back
seemingly out of nowhere unmasks himself
and reveals that he's eddie brock and
he's like no right i have my grudge with
peter parker if anybody's going to kill
spider-man it's going to be me right
like i'm going to be the one to kill him
which is kind of crazy because following
that instead of eddie brock becoming
venom as we normally expect instead what
he does is he basically takes the
tentacles of doctor octopus and then
becomes like eddie you know doc brock i
think is what they call them right
becomes like eddie brock doctor octopus
which is kind of cool it's something
that you've that we've never really seen
before and i like that idea the more i
see different writers like chipsydarsky
take these traditional roles that belong
to like heroes and villains and then
give them to somebody else the more i
like it man it makes you think of the
possibilities right i mean if everything
just stayed the same forever it'd be
boring as hell
right like it's cool to see different
characters playing these roles and so
the results of this is that bringing the
entire team together right even though
you have otto octavius who was killed by
brock they're like okay i mean whatever
you know let's kind of bring this guy on
board you've got a pretty solid team
here right i mean like this group and
it's easy to overlook the power of the
sinister six right but you've got like
mysterio you got electro you got rhino
you got craven you've got some pretty
heavy hitters here these guys under
normal circumstances would be more than
enough to take out spider-man and so
that's the crazy thing is that once
spider-man arrives on the scene mysterio
immediately initiates his his basically
his illusions and then tells everybody
keep your devices on right so that you
guys can essentially see the real world
and peter will be the only one who'll be
caught up in the illusion that i'm
creating but the crazy thing about this
is that peter is able to decipher pretty
fast that there's an illusion created
here by mysterio and actually moving
underground which is a pretty cool
concept like literally traveling
underground and because of the fact that
they can't locate him they can't see
where he is they figure out like he's
gone underground he immediately comes up
kills mysterio right as soon as
mysterio's dead right it's the death of
the queen in the chessboard but at that
point if you don't know what you're
doing the game is over and these guys
don't know what they're doing and so the
game is over this fight is one of the
quickest ass weapons that you're ever
going to see in the history of comics it
goes by so fast like rhino charges bam
gets punched right eddie brock goes
after him eddie brock gets incapacitated
right he'll get killed he just gets
knocked the heck out you immediately
have electro who goes to attack peter
and electro's kill right like these guys
are just killed so fast so quick so you
ultimately end up having j jonah jameson
who shows up in a kind of mechanized
suit and because of the fact that the
actions of electro had sparked a fire
before his death the net of craven
actually ensnares peter so he simply
just can't escape and ultimately the
symbiote seems to succumb to the fire
right basically seems to end up burning
alive and so following that j jonah
jameson is one surprised to learn that
it's peter parker which is kind of a
shock to him right like it's almost a
disappointment that it turned out to be
peter and two kraven's knocked
unconscious and so at that point
everybody except for jay jonah jameson
eddie brock and craven the hunter have
all been killed by peter up to this
point 11 people have been killed by
peter parker and spider-man 11 villains
all killed by peter parker ruthlessly
and with no remorse whatsoever the funny
thing about this and as you would expect
right the day save they ride off into
the sunset in order to you know bring
peter parker to terms for everything
he's done of course the symbiote or at
least a portion of it remains in the
back of the of the van and that's when
everything begins to pop off is because
you end up coming to this realization
that in the aftermath of wilson fisk's
death that a kind of doomsday situation
or doomsday scenario that he had
initiated is that peter parker's
identity is let out into the world and
so everybody realizes peter parker
spider-man i.e peter parker had killed
all these villains the other part of
this is that with the symbiote that had
essentially been taken by read and
examined that what had happened is that
the simeon itself had actually escaped
and then bonded itself not only to reed
richards but has also taken over ben
grimm the thing right so at this point
now it's weaponized itself and so
following that like literally it starts
taking over all these people and before
anybody really has any any understanding
of like what it is they're supposed to
do the entire backstreet building has
essentially been taken over so there's
no real time to like prosecute peter
hand him to the feds and even if there
was it's like okay but like we'll do
that after this because there's far more
important things going on here and so
you essentially have a full coming
together of the avengers and the x-men
as they existed at that point in time
right that's why iron man looks the way
he does that's why the x-men is really
more x factor than the x-men or anything
else she-hulk hasn't changed in decades
which is one of the reasons why nobody
cares about her character but the
important thing about this is that it's
kind of the the the old school roster of
the avengers and x factor kind of the
original x-men on a new team coming
together in an effort to like find a way
to basically end this now the funny
thing about this is that the symbiote
operating with the intelligence of reed
richards means it knows all the
strengths and all the weaknesses of the
venom symbiote and so what that does is
it allows the venom symbiote to
literally find ways or at least use the
technology of reed to protect itself and
so where you have spider-man and you
have johnny storm who make their way
into the building along with mary jane
watson which i don't even know what she
was gonna do they basically find out the
symbiote has taken over everybody in the
building right so literally they're
walking into what's basically a death
trap not only that you've got ben grimm
the thing who's a guy that's on par with
the incredible hulk in his base form so
obviously this guy's a heavy hitter so
he's not easily defeated and in fact
peter does everything he can against
this guy even says like i'm angry and
when i'm angry i'm unstoppable no quips
no pulling punches ben can take it right
and just starts to pummel ben as best he
can but at the end of the day peter
parker is still not 100 after everything
has happened and ben graham's able to
get the upper hand now the the idea of
ben grimm fighting peter is if anything
really more of a distraction but where
ben graham is knocked out of the
building and then basically met by all
the other avengers and they're like
we're here to help then ultimately
they're all taken over by the symbiote
so now you've basically got x factor and
the avengers who have all basically been
conquered by the symbiote itself that
only johnny storm and peter parker are
really the last ones left on top of that
with the venom symbiote controlling reed
and the technology at his disposal now
peter and johnny storm have to contend
with all of them and so at that point
it's an act of desperation and in fact
you see something that you don't really
see very often which is peter running
and hiding now keep in mind it's not
peter being a coward he's not like oh my
god like we're so screwed and then just
runs in heights but it's one of those
things where the the actions of peter is
to really kind of keep himself
momentarily hidden away so he can kind
of gather himself and figure out what
their next step needs to be of course it
also gives johnny storm a chance to get
mary jane watson out of there right
because the last thing peter needs is
for mary jane watson to die and so at
that point it comes down to peter and it
comes down to johnny storm to figure out
what their next step is going to be now
on the outside you also get another
distraction in the form of susan storm
right the invisible woman she creates
force fields things like that she's
there to kind of distract the other
heroes that are basically taken over by
the symbiotes to make sure that they
don't really get in the way of what it
is that peter's trying to do and also
just trying to fight off things as best
she can right it's just you know
superheroes doing superhero things and
so ultimately you end up having peter
parker coming to this realization that
because of the fact that the symbiote
had taken over reed richards and then in
turn had used itself to bond itself to
other members out there that by taking
out the symbiote as it's bonded to read
would be like driving a dagger through
or driving a stake to the heart of a
vampire it would kill the subservient
vampires that have been created by that
initial vampire and so essentially
defeating the symbiote as it's bonded to
reed will basically free everybody else
but it's no small feat because a
symbiote won't simply just leave and
because of the fact that it's aware of
all his weaknesses the various things
that all these heroes could do to try to
overcome its weaknesses things like fire
things like sonics will not readily work
and so what they need is some kind of
another plan and so what you get is a
plan that's kind of concocted between uh
between peter and johnny storm which is
pretty genius right the way this works
is that peter says okay so in order to
overcome this symbiote i'm gonna have to
get the symbiote to leave reed richards
and to bond itself to me and everything
that symbiotes doing is to try to
convince me that it's right that its way
of doing things is the right way of
doing things and so because of that he's
like the symbiote basically wants to
return to me right that's essentially
what it is that if you could call it
love that's what the symbiote feels and
so the response of peter once he shows
up and actually starts talking to the
symbiote is okay look i know that at the
root of what you feel is some twisted
version of love and you could just take
me over like that much i know like i'm
standing here and you could just use
your abilities and just take me in as
some kind of a servant of yourself but
how satisfying would that be right
forcing me to merge with you if you let
mary jane live if you stop possessing
the other heroes then i'll give myself
over willingly and the response of the
simian is okay we can do that the
problem is this guy reed is too smart
right this guy will find a way to
destroy me while i while i've basically
possessed you we can't let him lift and
the symbiote kills reed right just kills
reed richards right on the spot and in
that moment peter parker takes off back
into the backstreet building right mad
as hell takes off back back into the
backstreet building and then runs as
fast as it possibly can and so what you
end up getting is a symbiote of course
chasing after him and then getting him
down into a corner and that's where you
end up finding out the trap that was set
is that peter parker got his hands on an
image inducer and the image inducer was
given to johnny storm to make johnny
storm look like peter parker this is not
peter this is johnny storm when the
symbiote immediately sees peter and then
encases itself around peter parker
johnny's storm reveals the ruse and then
it's just like flame on right and then
just torches this thing on the spot i
gotta say it's the most creative way to
kill a symbiote that i have ever seen it
is so cool i never saw this coming right
i mean the story itself was a little
you know but the idea of the or the way
in which they killed the simian by the
way that chips and rc came up with this
which is so like trick the symbiote into
believing that it's actually uh peter
instead of johnny storm was pretty cool
one of the big issues that you have with
this and those of you guys who are
experienced with the venom scene will
probably have spotted this right off the
bat that the the symbiote when it was
bonded to peter shared almost something
like a sixth sense right almost a sense
in and of itself to where it would have
known right off the bat that that's not
pure right unless the image inducer was
so advanced that it would have tricked
the senses of the symbiote which there
doesn't seem to be an indication that
was the case and so with that being
being the case that ultimately this
symbiote is basically destroyed right
it's totally eradicated and so following
that of course everybody just kind of
mourns read the fact that reid's
basically dead and then in turn peter
ends up going to trial now the crazy
thing about this is that with peter
being on trial the fact that like
captain america and these other
individuals out there uh basically
testifying to the fact that when they
were possessed by the symbiote they
couldn't control themselves right they
didn't have the ability to stop
themselves from doing the things that
the symbiote was making them do that it
basically created the case that peter
being possessed by the symbiote that it
wasn't really peter it was the symbiote
right so peter is an innocent person
like by all standards of measurement it
would have been no different if somebody
had used mind control and took over the
body of peter and then made peter do
things right the funny thing about this
and this is the part that peter kind of
keeps to himself and it's something that
he doesn't even reveal to mj is that he
willingly gave in to the symbiote he
knew what was going to happen what he
was possessed by the symbiote but he and
the symbiote shared a similar mind it's
his dark secret he doesn't tell anybody
and so the funny thing is that the story
effectively ends with basically peter
being approached by uh by susan storm
and then being told look with everything
that's happened right reed's death was
not your fault none of us are strangers
to tragedy i know you aren't right one
of our first tragedies was that rocket
flight that gave us all powers you know
that turned ben grimm into the thing and
all that kind of stuff right nobody
knows this but reed almost died from the
guilt of that but instead of succumbing
he did something remarkable he took that
tragedy that guilt and turned it into
something good he helped ben helped all
of us become heroes and that's when she
approaches them and says we want you to
not necessarily replace reed richards
but just to step in and take this
tragedy that you've experienced and
turned it into something that you can
build right become a part of the
fantastic four and become a part of this
grander superhero community this sort of
a step above or you know where you work
it's a pretty ironic set of
circumstances peter gives in to the
symbiote knowing that the symbiont is
going to basically begin a path of death
and destruction because peter actually
wants it right and then in turn a
massive conflict in suits keeping this
entire secret to himself he's now
effectively rewarded for his actions
it's pretty wild but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end let me know what you guys think
about this story down in the in the
comments section i'm really curious i've
seen pretty divisive reviews on it some
people loved it some people didn't
really like it at all but let me know
what you guys think thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace